[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and
i'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting that's right
we're back in our zone we're back at the
at the table
sitting a little further apart you know
we were sitting when we were at the
other house
too close a little too close a little
too close we're not six feet apart
that's because me and you
are a pod we're never succeed we don't
be honest we're not
we don't practice social distancing
between the two of us
but this is a slightly more social we
are we are a partnership of creativity
right yeah pod
and that's why we're that's why we're
here creative pod
who does a podcast this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting
we're going to discuss our relationship
with board games
i thought you're going to stop at
relationship so many others thought the
same thing
i'm sure we'll talk about our
relationship
there's a number of relationships that
are impacted by
this board game conversation if you
don't like board games
this podcast is for you and if you do
like board games this
podcast is also for you and if you're
indifferent to board games and you have
sort of uh
i mean yeah i'll take it if somebody
offers a relationship with
board games this podcast is for you and
by this podcast we mean this episode
and end the whole show yeah is
a podcast episode a podcast
it's an episode uh i i gotta ask you
another question because
uh i didn't know the answer to that one
i just want to sweep it under the rug
are you having ant problems at your
house it is so hot i mean
california is freaking burning it is it
is
is sad like i've i've looked at it's and
it's so hot
like last week it was record-breaking
temperatures
in our zone like 105 degree days
and that's the interesting thing that we
discovered about california that we
didn't know until we moved
here you know back in north carolina
september rolls around and yeah it's
still hot but it's
starting to change it's starting to say
okay okay okay enough already
yeah creeping up on fall but in southern
california september
is like we just getting started y'all
it's it's i remember the first year we
moved here august september is really
hot
typically yeah i remember being 115
degrees in october
in burbank and i was like uh i didn't i
didn't think this is
what it was supposed to be so yeah it's
super hot but it's hot fires are
everywhere
and i think that's why like all of these
insects are now inside of my house it's
it's
you know it's hot when it's too hot for
an insect
i mean can a insect they're used to 100
degree temperature they can do that they
have an exoskeleton
apparently apparently they're sensitive
when it gets to that temperature because
i think that is the reason
there's just like i looked at in jade's
dog bowl
and i went over there because
i knew there was still food in it and
but she was like
she was like she'd bark and she'd look
at me
and i was like you're you're asking for
food but you've already got food
well you know where this is going i walk
over there there's more ants in the bowl
than there is food
and she doesn't she's not ants are not
on the menu menu nope
um she did not want to eat the ants so i
like i
clean out the whole bowl and then
christie starts
she found the spray i didn't even know
we had it oh we got lots of sprays
because we
we deal with this what we all the time
we got i mean i got natural sprays
that don't actually harm the humans and
the pets
and then when things get real bad all
bets are off and we harm everyone
including us
she let loose with this spray i mean
i've i've
totally relocated jade's bowl to
somewhere else because
i know that these ants are talking to
each other because there's a whole
pheromone
there's a whole line of ant they like
make a trail trail of scent
and then it's it's going up and it's
going like through some there's no hole
next to the window but somehow oh they
don't need a hole they don't need a hole
they're just coming in
i think they ca they can just talk about
teleportation because they
they copper they're the ones who know
how to teleport yeah they copper filled
it right through the wall sometimes this
morning
i went back into my bathroom to uh
take a shower and brush my teeth and get
ready to come in here i appreciate you
doing that by the way hey you know
keeping up with
regular hygiene just for keeping it
fresh i mean i'm still shaving and
everything
yeah i'm shaving under my beard and
right
on my cheeks where there's some weird
hairs that grow up above the line
oh really you want to have that
eyebrowed a beard connection happening
what just i don't think that would ever
happen i think they're going to have a
cover
i have a couple of hairs that are like
should we
should we see if we could go up higher
on the face yeah yeah it's like no you
can't
those hairs are like the first ants that
are like whoa they're frontiers
it's cooler in here there's dog food i'm
gonna
excrete some sort of path or maybe they
just walk back
and but i my thing is
if i get every ant that's here
and i corral them all together and then
i spray them and mop them up and like
throw them in the trash can
there's no then there's none to go back
and communicate but am i just
am i getting them confused with bees and
is it some pheromone trail that they're
dropping because
i'm also spraying that i think i got it
covered but my point is
i went back upstairs you know i get up
i mosey downstairs i drink my coffee i
do some
meditating do some exercising i
eat my drink my breakfast then i come
back upstairs
and i get ready right brush my teeth
take a shower
it was at that point this morning that i
looked on my
bathroom counter and this is the second
floor of my house yeah
this is i mean there's never any food up
here
you don't do bedroom eating never never
as a policy we just don't there's never
any food
upstairs in our bedroom not like a
secret chocolate stash or anything
no no secrets you got a secret chocolate
sauce yeah because i got
chocolate in my you got night chocolate
yeah yeah i'm like a
i'm like a middle-aged woman reading a
romance novel i got
dark chocolate bars in my bedside table
uh because well you better watch out
because the kids are gonna find
the kids you gotta you got a kid-free
stash yeah
they'll find the chocolate and yes it is
safe for my dog i understand that it's
deadly to dogs but barbara cannot get in
there and she's done open
drawers she's never tried i go back up
there and then right there
on my kitchen counter where i left it
like i do every morning is my grinder
you know what i'm talking about your
grinder my
my teeth insert thingy that that keeps
you from growing keeps my teeth from
grinding i would call that a
mouth guard and not a grinder a
mouthpiece could get confusing i call it
my grinder because it
i grind it instead of grinding my teeth
against each other well
it's easy to you know same number of
syllables and also doesn't
lead people to you know incorrect
conclusions just call it a mouth guard
and you'll seem like steph curry you
know where this is going
ants all over my grinder
a bunch of them yeah and i'm like
oh my gosh and so i'm rinsing off
the mouthpiece and i'm i'm i'm getting
all these ants to go down in the flood
of my sink and i'm fine you feel bad and
i'm raking them in there do you feel bad
in that moment that they're that they're
all drowning
uh no i'm angry i'm like i
this this this has got to stop you take
pleasure in murdering them no
i guess the thought does cross my mind
because i do it's like what are they
are they feeling i know they're not
feeling anything christie walks in at
that moment
and i was like look at this she's like
god
why are they on that and i'm like
because it's like my spit they're they
want to eat my dick
it's different they will ants will
congregate around it isn't just food
sources or sugar
sometimes it's electronics like there's
something about the vibration
of a certain like what based on they'll
find a walkie-talkie and they'll get on
that based on the mouthpiece
i'm i'm if i lay still enough in my bed
am i going to wake up with a mouth full
of ants
is that how bad things have got you'd
probably have to die first
or at least be rendered unconscious for
a long period of time also rats can eat
your toes when you're when you're
unconscious
or your nose if you have a rat problem
so do you have ants crawling all over
your house it's funny because
we started noticing ants earlier in the
summer
and like you know we've got the the
driveway
that's got like the white wall on one
side and so
very often as i'm kind of leaving the
drive you know leaving during the
morning or walking up and down the
driveway there's all kinds of trails
that they will create on that wall
and you can see it and so that's when
i'm like oh they're active again
uh i've tried so many different things
oh excuse me
for some reason i picked up a dr pepper
on the other side and i'm drinking it
and
the other side the other side you
crossed over
and how do we know cause he came back by
the doctor almost died
the other side of the building is what i
meant
but um i thought that this year
they were going to be worse because i
started seeing them earlier and they in
one morning
uh shepherd was like dad there's all
kinds of ants in the guest
bathroom um but it hasn't been that bad
but the thing that we've noticed
is spiders spiders too yeah and flies
the other night flies before we got
ready to eat dinner
um jesse had left the door open for
barbara to go
out and
she left it open for too long i you know
what i have seen a few flies at my house
i'll take that back so we're getting
ready to eat dinner and jesse's like
could you kill some of those flies
because she knows me i'm the fly
assassin she knows i take a certain
amount of pride in my work
and you know my technique slapping above
them and trapping them and
you anticipate their exit and exit right
into my hands
and you slap right at that spot now
i proceeded to before we eat
in approximately a 12-minute period
murder seven flies in my kitchen
and there were still three flying around
there was a total of ten
that we found in the kitchen oh wow now
and jesse was like what is happening
i was like it's so hot yeah they feel
that ac
coming out and they're like oh it's nice
in there and they come in there
now i bet somebody's got a mouthpiece to
get back to
this what i begin to do and it
really upsets my wife and i don't quite
understand it
i begin to talk junk to the flies
and so what i'm doing is i take a couple
of them out like the fat ones that are
easy and slow
and then we start getting down to the
nimble ones what are the fat ones full
of
life i think they've just been around i
think there's a lot but that
that would be a mosquito i don't know
how long flies
are alive uh i can't it can't be more
than a few weeks right
and i think that those big ass flies are
at the end of their life cycle and they
kind of
they go into they go inside somewhere
and they get slow and they become easy
targets
but when it gets down to those last
three or four flies and they're smaller
and they're more nimble
i begin to say you've made it this far
you think you're out of the woods you've
seen your comrades go down one by one
you say this out loud yes i begin to
speak to them i think you're
okay and i say here's the thing
these my friends are your last moments
on earth
make the most of it and jesse's like
please shut up she's like
don't talk that way it makes me feel bad
about the flies you're like
i'm like you're the one who asked me to
kill them woman you're a bloodlusting
zealot
despot i think it's the fact that i
don't believe in doing harm to
living beings in general and especially
ones that can like comprehend
the difference between life and death or
pain and not pain and it's not just a
stimulus you know
let's just say mammals you don't like to
kill a mammal right yeah
yeah i i do not like to kill a mammal
no i don't like the idea of mammals
getting killed yes i'm a meat eater yes
it's hypocritical we'll get to that in
10 years okay
but back mark your calendar don't worry
we'll get to it
but uh with flies you're an easy target
it feels like i can take a little bit of
my aggression out i mean everybody's got
aggression you kind of need to deal with
it in some way
and i feel like i bite a pillow yeah in
the pillow
the pillow can't die i mean what have i
grinded on my grinder when i slap
the hell out of that fly and he dies
and i throw him in the trash i'm like i
i just did something
i mean that fly was gonna be alive for
another week maybe did you feel better
yeah i do and but my wife makes me think
a little too much about
it she's like i don't like it when you
start talking to them like that
and i'm like but i i do it you could
just leave the room and let me talk junk
to the flies
the weird thing is that i'm the lord of
the flies they don't think about it they
can't communicate and
you know and they don't have emotions
associated
with being slap murdered
so the disturbing part is that you're
kind of
you're putting the things on them that
might deter
others from then killing them but you're
like you're slathering that on them
hey feel this think about what i'm about
to do
i'm talking to them like i'm killing
humans right because it seems
more substantial that's why it's
troubling let me just okay
i'm on jesse's side okay can i take one
additional little tangent you're gonna
i don't know what you're gonna think
about this idea but
last night we were watching the most
recent season of if you're gonna say
that you then eat the flies no
i don't want to hear it last night we
were uh i'm just trying
this is my reality i'm opening my mind
and my heart
to you into you okay you know and i know
being vulnerable can get you in trouble
but i'm going for it okay
so i was watching the latest season of
married at first sight
uh with jesse and i don't like the
people this season
i like them less than i didn't like the
people last season or i hate them more
than i hated the people last
i actually started liking some of the
people in the previous season but i
don't like any of these couples yet
right there's five couples for the first
time ever five
so so you're talking about killing them
what no well no what i told jesse
is i was like what do you think in the
future i
think there might be a feature where you
get so
upset with the characters on a reality
show
that you can like press a command into
the device that you're watching and
they'll like
die on screen just for your own personal
satisfaction
and they won't be a part of the show
anymore like you know that level of
interaction but they don't really die
it's just like it's just like a
it's first like a first person shooter
but it's the show that you're watching
like i hate that character so much
or i hate this couple and you press a
button and they both go
and they fall down and die on the show
and i was like i know that's demented
but
i hate this one couple in particular
they cringe make me cringe so hard
that i i want to hurt them and i know
that's wrong
but if i see it as just the thing that's
happening in media like in video games
and it's not real
it's all just portrayed and acted it
feels like it would be okay
bring this to your therapist and then
once
but what do you think about that feature
it could it could maybe it's just
you could tickle the characters
logistically it doesn't work no but on
but no no in the future they can do
anything if it was like on a journal
the only one watching that show what i'm
saying yeah but your feed is your feed
and
you tickle the person they laugh on your
feed
it's interactive it's personalized well
listen but you poke them hard enough
it's like a voodoo doll and they get
hurt
so you want to have personalized vr
basically it's well it's it's a
personalized
reality show yeah that i can interact
with
it's like a video it's like a it's a
video game yes
it's a video game but it's a reality
show i think this is gonna happen
but but where you were just going with
the vr i think a vr
game in which you're in a kitchen and
you're killing flies with your two vr
hands that's just
that's just a phone app well i guess no
you got to be vr
you got to have that i'm going to make
that game fly
fly assassin fly assassin's creed
i don't i'm going to jump on that train
i don't kill
any flies in my house because jade kills
him that's the only
reason she gets kills flies yes she's
seven inches tall does she kill the ones
that are above her
she waits for him to come down and they
always do
and she kills them she yeah she she she
bites them and then they're on the
ground and she sniffs them
and i think she eats them when i'm not
looking how how reliable is she because
if we could work together
i'll rent her out to you i'll go for the
high she'll go for the low
yeah yeah could be a no-fly it's gonna
escape us you could be an exterminating
doggy man duo we're gonna talk about
board games but we do want to remind you
if you watch gmm
you know about this already vote like a
beast.com this is a website that we put
together because we
are really trying to motivate people to
take part in the election
this year yeah i've you know it's
i remember back when we were um
lads when we were at bowie's creek
elementary school i guess we were in
eighth grade we could it was the it was
the clinton
it was when clinton won the presidential
election that would have been uh
so clinton bush never been a freshman
here was it
who did he run against yeah it was bush
going for a second yeah yeah
um the first bush herbert walker
and uh i remember being really into that
like all the kids in the school voted in
the school-wide election
school-wide election that it was very
exciting
and i don't and i i don't remember being
that heated either it was just
fun you know it's like this is not fun
but for the first time since that
election
i actually feel like oh my gosh
this matters now of course i've i've
voted for the first time since 92.
this is link's not been really been
paying attention it's
it's i mean you know that elections
matter and
but it's very palpable
to me this time around and there's
there's just a level of
urgency that i i haven't felt well i
think a lot of people you know what
we'll say that because
uh and i don't think that's true but
but that is no no no i think you know i
think
you think about how much political
discourse well let me clarify what i
think is
was true i think all elections are
extremely important that's what i that's
what i mean
but there is something about this
election for me personally
that i'm the most engaged i've ever been
i don't know
i can't speak for a lot of people what
i'm getting at is the reason you speak
for a lot of people is because
many people who didn't care at all about
politics and i'm not saying you didn't
care all about politics but you're not
really a politically motivated person
right but a lot of people who are in
that boat
have seen what's happened in our country
over the past four years and
how think about how much we talk about
the president in a way that we have
never talked about a president right
the news is so dominated by political
discourse
we're even more polarized than we were
four years ago like
and so a lot of people are like i guess
i'm going to be a part of this process
and yeah we feel the same thing and on
good mythical morning
there are certain you know we don't get
political
on the show um by and large
you know it's like we try we try to
preserve that space
to be an escape from um
i don't know a lot of places
if you find yourself witnessing or being
a part of like a twitter war
or some sort of ugly back and forth on
facebook and you know we don't want to
bring that into good mythical morning
you know i don't i don't want to bring
that type of
energy into my life personally but
we did want to do something to mobilize
everyone to to vote yeah and to re
to to help make the each person's
decision
uh to enable their decision as much as
possible whatever their decision may be
voting like a beast is go it goes beyond
the really important first step which is
just registering to vote and being ready
to vote which is important
so you can do that at vote like a beast
but the sort of the next layer
that we think is important is informing
yourself right
because you as a citizen who is eligible
to vote
you the most clear way that you can
actually
let your voice be heard according to the
issues that you find important is by
exercising your right to vote
and a lot of times people are just like
ah my vote really doesn't count
it kind of gets lost in the mix and uh
but the collect the collective power of
our voices
is incredibly important i mean it's the
collective
uh power of the vote consists of
individual voters like you
and when you can make the connection
between what you believe and what you
find to be important and what you would
like to see happen in
your country to the candidates who have
policies that they've laid out publicly
that makes you an informed voter so the
we have tools on the site that
help make those connections profiles of
candidates we link out to resources that
we've kind of you know
brought together aggregated into one
place to make
you have the option of being an informed
voter to the point where you can
actually take
a voter guide into the ballot box if
you're voting in person or you can have
it right there when you're voting by
mail so you can make choices that are
according to your
interest and how you are informed about
the issues right so
it's all in one place we try to make it
as simple as possible to empower
you to vote according to your conscience
that's votelikeabeast.com we invite you
to check it out
and share that with people um
it's nonpartisan go for it
vote like a beast
let's talk about the shirt that you're
wearing uh have you joined a softball
team
um no have you ever thought about it
i'm open to anything now that
involves like getting out and like
playing with people whenever the time
comes that i can do that again
okay softball it is so it might be
softball and i've you know i've got the
shirt
the mythical softball team join up now
you also can get a pennant
mythical.com i think it's technically
the saw the baseball tee
but you know what the rules are almost
exactly the same
the balls are bigger balls are bigger
hey listen you can pick a bigger ball
always do that softball over baseball
mythical.com mythical.com rep your boys
when you're out there on the
on the diamond and bring the diamond
with you wherever you go
okay so let's get into board games you
know i wanted to talk about this because
i'm
i'm on a journey okay i know we're all
on a journey but
i'd like to think that i am on a very
specific and special yeah everybody
thinks their journey everybody thinks
their journey is the most important one
that's what makes you human and i've
come to an intersection
that involves board games we talked
about our vacations
a few episodes back and uh the one thing
that i kept from you
because it was so special to my heart
and i didn't you know i just didn't know
if i wanted to share it
was well and really we ran out of time
because i think we ended up talking
about
probably reality yeah i'm sure it was
sure
we are not a board game plane family
but christy packed these board games i
didn't even know we had
and i'm like you know what i saw
a couple of board games and the first
one that we ended up playing was code
names and
the reason why is because we played code
names i learned code names at your house
in your monthly game night which is
currently on coved hiatus
and i was like you know what this isn't
a i would not call that a board game
i'll call it a party game
okay but i think i'm i don't have the
terminology right
because there's just beginning there's a
board though there is a
there is a board for those of you don't
know how code name works
um well i can't explain it
it's a it's a verbal game where you're
divided into two teams
so with our family it was uh gracie was
there with us
and so it was three against three and um
i think she brought this game actually i
was like oh i love this game
because it's not a strategy game it's a
verbal game where you're like giving
clues i'll try to quickly explain the
rules and it probably won't mean
anything to you
so i'll make it quick but basically you
have
a board in front of you that has a
series of words on it yeah you put cards
down and it's one word per card and
there's
and they're in a mosaic and you are
trying to get your team
to guess the words
that are associated with your team and
not guess the words that are associated
with the other team
and the more that and you can only give
one word clues
and so you're trying to come up with
when it's your turn and basically
you have one person who is the clue
giver for that realm for the team
and you're trying to come up with one
word
that will connect as many of those words
on the board that are your words so if
it was like
saturn space and telescope you might say
astronomy
but if you had saturn in space and you
and i are the clue givers for our
opposite teams
i also know which which words are yours
and if i had venus
if venus or zeros i can't you know
i can't i could say three astronomy and
that means
three of the words on the board could be
associated with astronomy and then
everyone on my team
verbally processes and and it's kind of
torturous to then give the clue and
listen but it's very fun
i believe it to be it's a great i
believe it to be
the best it is the best game that we
have played at game night
yeah it's it's good for a party it's
there's not
a lot of strategy involved um there's a
lot of interplay between
all the players so we started playing
code names pictures as well which is the
same thing but it's oh it's sequel
you haven't played that i thought it was
well i never played that it's the same
exact thing except it's pictures instead
of words
the rules are exactly the same and what
you're trying to in the way you're
giving clues is exactly the same but
you're trying to get them to guess these
pictures
and it's weird because it'll be like
these weird symbolic
sort of mosaic type symbol pictures
that are open to interpretation open to
interpretation so you have to
find what your partner and your team is
thinking and it's great
we were having a lot of fun and it was
like
oh my gosh this is exactly what i hoped
our vacation would be
our family is gathered around a table
we're playing a game together
and why do you and everybody's vacation
to well we don't break out the board
games we don't own code names
um and yeah because i've i've never
i've never enjoyed board games i'll get
into that more so but then
there were two nights of playing code
names and boy every
everybody was into there was food there
was drink there was music there was code
names
there was togetherness alcohol for the
whole family the whole family
jade was drunk off heart periasse
um and then i'm looking over there and
i'd seen this other
game and i was like katan
or is it katan i think katan is
the correct pronunciation but katan
is what i was like this is settlers of
catan did you i didn't know we owned
this and it was a brand new
junior or regular regular and christy
had christy had bought this thing
and so the third morning after the two
nights of code names i'm like
you know what i'ma open this up never
been played fresh out of the box i was
reading about i was like
we're gonna do this we're gonna do this
now i had heard about this game and i'm
like
this is this is not gonna be for me this
is a strategy game
i've always hated strategy i've never
had a good experience with a strategy
game and again we'll get we can
i'm curious about your past and your
perspective which i think is different
than mine
but we can go into the reasons why but
i'm like you know what
it was such a good experience i want
this quintessential strategy board game
and we should give it a shot it's an
intricate board
we got a pun we got to pull everything
out and set it up for the first time
lando even if he can't follow the game
because he's 10 years old
he'll enjoy setting it up well actually
he did enjoy playing the game
and followed just like anybody else or
he was as good as me
and we had a great experience playing uh
what i would call settlers of katan but
how many
how long did it the box just says
content how did how long did it take
um because we were learning and they do
a really good job of like if you're just
learning
you kind of skip ahead a little bit they
kind of prime the game a little bit for
you so you have the
momentum of the beginning have you ever
played it yeah
i've never ever played it i'd only heard
of it
and um i think we it was like an hour
and a half
maybe maybe almost two hours
and um i loved it
the reason why i loved it was because i
mean you're like
you're you trade with people in order to
like
you to settle this land called kittan
katan who knows i we we we settled on it
being catan
that in the neil house we call it catan
i think that's fine i think that might
be right you build roads you build
settlements and then you turn them into
cities and then it
you know you have to do it by like
trading sheep for brick
and you're trading with people and
there's some strategy involved but it's
not
too crazy i mean i
we were just as a flashback when
christie and i were
first married before we started having
kids we were invited to
we had these friends of the older couple
they had some kids who were like
middle schoolers and they said we want
you to come over and play risk with us
and it was like the worst night of my
life they were so
into it i didn't know how to play and i
i just don't i would at that night i
concluded you know what
i don't i can't i can't get this it's
very frustrating it lasts forever
i just don't have a mind for strategy i
don't have a strategy mind
you know what it's my shortcoming i'm
not going to blame it on them but they
are really into it and it's a little bit
alienating and why is this taking
forever let's just talk
risk is its own is his own thing we used
to
um so just to complete my thought i
thought i would hate
i was like very proud of myself because
here i am doing a strategy game and it
seems like everybody's involved and i'm
like
i'm actually following this turns out
when i looked online
to find other games like katan
that we could also play it's categorized
as a light
strategy game so that kind of yeah
there's not a lot to it that yeah
that's not my ego i think it's fun now
speaking of risk because
you know we used to play
like me and my father-in-law my
brother-in-law and like
an assorted bunch you've ever happened
to be around sometimes it was
my wife's cousin that was there as well
when they were in town
would play these
really intense long
games of risk and the thing about risk
is
the games can last for hours right it's
not it's
it's i mean we would sometimes go into
these like three or four hour long
games because it kept going back and
forth and
everyone who was playing like you think
i'm competitive
i was easily the least competitive
in this group between my father-in-law
my brother-in-law and
my wife's cousin as long as everybody's
into it that's great no but what would
happen is
and this is what i want to get back to
asking you about because this this maps
onto like the way my family plays games
it would get my bro my father-in-law and
my brother-in-law
would sometimes i was like they're gonna
they're they're gonna fight they're
finally gonna fight
you know what i'm saying like fist
fighting because it was so
intense she would get so it would get so
intense and like you do these things
that like
with risk you have the option of like
i'm gonna team up with with this guy and
we're gonna sabotage you
and we're gonna take you out and a lot
of times we would do that to my
father-in-law because he was the best at
the game we've been playing for a long
time you know how he's so competitive
and so that that may nothing makes you
angrier than if you get
teamed up against it's not right there's
a little you can do and i was always
just kind of like
a little bit like switzerland i didn't
start in switzerland that's not a great
strategy
uh but i
i'm really competitive but i would just
kind of play it i was just like this is
entertaining because they're so
passionate about this
and if you go to somebody who's like
they've got their strategy down
you can't just and like that couple did
you a disservice
by inviting you into a game that
can be as intense as risk and not like
picking up on your signals that you were
not into it
or that maybe we should like play it in
a more
you know inviting way it reminds me of
the story of when we
back in 1909 it was 2003 probably
when we were on our staff training to go
on staff with campus crusade
yeah we went down to florida so we were
there like taking
seminary classes for a summer
and then also being beyond staff trained
in like everything we were going to do
and we became really good friends with
uh eric and natalie
uh who were from tennessee and with the
the six of us really
got along right we're all basically
newlyweds so we're newlyweds
and we just you know we we all liked
each other right
yeah and so we connected with them
probably more than anybody at staff
training and we got into playing not a
board game but a game party game
catchphrase
and the reason why we play that because
by that point
again that was around the same time as
the risk incident
and like in college we would play risk
some
like there were people who liked risk
and that was like by the i was
became convinced that like none of this
was for me
none of these board games strategy games
but
party games like catchphrase where it's
like it's quick and it's verbal and
it's it's fun and then it's over and you
can basically end it at any time
you know it's not just like you don't
have to invest the whole night in it
and then if it goes sideways or it gets
upset the learning curve is much lower
it's simple you sit down and you and you
get it and then
but i was i was very into and still am
very into something like catchphrase and
you know
we say this all the time you don't think
you're competitive i think you're just
as competitive as me
uh you just show it in a different way
but i think you hate to lose just as
much as me you're just better at
keeping it to yourself now the and you
would get super
super i don't know about that but we can
come back to it so we were
we would start playing this the six of
us and we would get so into it like
loud we were at the what was it the el
caribe it was at the
hotel that we were like apartment
building
i mean everyone do we need to explain
what catchphrase is
basically it's hot potato but like you
it's like password
there's a word you got to get people to
guess and you can't yeah you can't say
the word yeah and if it stops in your
hands you lose
um so we there was this other couple
that we didn't really know that well
but they were on they they were going to
go on staff with athletes in action
which is the campus crusade wing that
ministers to athletes
yeah they were like they had been
college athletes right
and so we were like these people are
competitive they surely
will be into how wild and crazy and
intense our games of catchphrase get
we invited him over one night yeah and
uh we're playing the game
and we're doing our typical like yelling
and like when somebody gets it wrong
everybody yells and somebody gets it
right everybody yells
and i'm just kind of noticing this
couple is shrinking they're not
really being loud at all they're not
they don't seem like they have the will
to win
and uh i think we scarred them forever
they did not ask to come back um
and we didn't talk a whole lot after
that i i think that
the energy we had it was like it was
just
it was fun to have energy so and i we
were playing guys against girls and i
think
one of the things that happens with me
when i'm playing a game is i get
like i'll say things and you're like is
he mad that
he seems mad and if you're the kind of
person who that kind of
comedic effect that kind of energy if
you knew you well no i'm just
i'm really getting into it but the
moment that like
we got to order a pizza i'm like which i
want on the pizza you know what i'm
saying it's like
i'm not actually mad i'm just really
intensely competing
it's like when you're playing basketball
with somebody and you're like talking
trash with them but then you're like hey
let's let's leave
in the same car it's it's just part of
the competitive spirit for me right
but some people don't respond well to
that and they
think oh these people must be
mad at each other and i think that that
wasn't how they're they were also
newlyweds
i don't think that's how it worked for
them whereas in our marriages i feel
like there was
a lot of like you know
you could be loud with your spouse and
it didn't mean you were mad with them
i mean that's definitely how me and
jesse are you know i think also when
you and i were on a team we could give
clues that seemed impossible
right because we knew how like we would
speak in code
and then it would be very frustrating
tough to beat we're tough to beat when
we're on the same
same team yeah so that was very that was
hilarious to us
and very decimating and frustrating to
but so when you're playing to
competitors katan
as a family they ended up just not
coming around right
so when you're playing katana as a
family are you it sounds to me what
what i was picturing in my mind as you
were talking about it isn't like
this is i want to win and that's the
main thing i'm thinking about it was
more
i'm having a great time with my family
that's what i was feeling
um lincoln is pretty competitive and
he's a very strategic thinker
i don't get that competitive directly
with i mean
i get competitive for the sake of uh
like entertaining myself and my family
but like
not in the same way that on game night
like i want to win and it becomes
personal
with my family it's like if shepard wins
this game that's awesome for him
so i'm not going to try to like
take him out i well i actually won
but i i wasn't like i wasn't like
gloating or anything i was actually
surprised because i
lincoln started he's he's he built all
of his cities
in this one place where like with
odds are he would end up getting all
these bricks he became
he was talking all this smack about hey
he was a brick factory
oh i got so much brick if anybody wants
any brick you got to come to me
you know that became fun when it was
this like you start to play a role in
the game of like you're the brick mogul
and then you know people think he
he's doing so well because he's got so
much brick then nobody wants to trade
with him and then he gets frustrated and
that's
that's that's that was fun fun to watch
him get frustrated yeah yeah yeah
but it um we were all
we're all doing the same thing and
having a good time
you know so then i'm coming i'm like
this is a new
this is a new era i think
i think we can do this at the beginning
of uh quarantine
i was thinking you know what it's puzzle
time it's game time
and on the mythical society
we were doing this thing early on where
um all the mythical crew members
were making videos from home about like
how what they were doing during
quarantine and making
uh suggestions about things that
um you could also enjoy
while while being isolated in quarantine
and uh
caleb our graphic designer who uh
give him credit for most all of the
merch
stuff that's designed he does the vast
majority of that
i i happen to be watching one of his
videos on the society and he started
talking about board games and he talked
about this one game called parks
and the way he talked about it it was it
was it was a strategy game where you
go through when you make your way
through all the national parks and i'm
like
my dream is to like be the dad who goes
to all the national parks with my family
while never leaving my living room so
now we can do that
here and it's like the artwork look
really cool and then it was
ended up i couldn't get one i had to
they have a kickstarter campaign for an
expansion and i
i ordered that i still haven't gotten it
but i was like you know what we're going
to get this parks game and this is going
to be
the new family thing hasn't happened but
i do
that's that's the next thing i'm excited
about we come back from the beach
and i'm like all right every sunday
that's going to be our game time and so
you know me i'm like
i'm excited about katan that's what
we're going to play
and i thought everybody else would be
excited this is the new neil thing
tabletop gaming and then lily's like
i don't want to play that that game's
stupid i was like it wasn't
it wasn't stupid two days ago she was
like shaping bricks
not for me you ran into a teenage
mentality yeah i'm like
you just made me some i was like well
we're gonna play a game
and we ended up playing the star we had
a star wars version of
clue which that we didn't even finish
i was like look at what happened fizzled
out physically
you know and then lincoln's a few the
next weekend
lincoln's like we should play among us
i'm like
tabletop gaming he was like no we each
need to be on our phones it's a it's a
it's a video game on your phone that
you you play it's fun with five people
but you can't talk to each other
and even though we're in the same room
you got to act like we're like in
different rooms
wow okay yeah and i'm like
seriously i was like i told lily i was
like if we play clue
next time we are going to go back to
catan katan
and we're going to like it we are going
to like it that's the dead spirit and
then
we need to get your now we're playing
among us which is
actually a pretty it's it's a very fun
game is it one of those games where like
you're all looking at the television
like uh those trivia games you're all
looking at this
this um spaceship schematic and you're
running around
and um you're a crew member but then one
person is an imposter and he's
sabotaging everything on the ship and
killing people
and then you have to um if you're a crew
member
and every time you play the game you're
randomly assigned you have to perform
tasks to like run around the ship and
and do things
but if you're the imposter you have to
act like you're doing things but then
when you're along with somebody you have
to kill him
and then when you when when a crew
member finds someone dead
they have to report dead body and then
everybody comes together and you discuss
like you actually can talk at that point
about who you think the imposter is
so it's got like a mafia werewolf kind
of vibe i think
yeah but it's mostly in in this gaming
world
of course i'm so freaking oblivious to
how to play a video game
that they're just laughing at me the
whole time and then ultimately getting
angry at me because i don't know what a
dead body looks like
and i don't know how to i don't know how
to move around and like
he was standing still for a really long
time he must have been
he must be the the the killer like no i
don't know how to move
it's like i don't know how to move yeah
i got stuck
so we quickly moved somehow my family
has taken us away
from our new identity as a board gaming
family back into like our own
phone zone well but i think you this is
still a victory to be celebrated yes
right because
first of all the distinction between
board games and party games
is one that in video games blurring
no i'm just saying that when it comes to
what it is that you're trying to
accomplish which is
doing something i'm not going to say not
on screens because that is on screens
but doing something together that's fun
as a family creating family memories
the distinction between the board games
and party games it doesn't matter
i was happy that most everybody was
willing to play that game
at least three times until it was like
somebody was like i don't want to do
this anymore well
i'm going to my room you can't go to
your room the thing that you're always
dealing with when it comes to teenagers
uh
is is them being on their phones and
then being in contact
with their friends girlfriends whatever
whatever the
people that they stay in contact with
their attention spans are really short
and it's very difficult for them to
unplug from being in contact right
so and also just their attention spans
are short in general i mean
you know we watch a lot of movies and i
try to
introduce the kids to you know movies
that i grew up with and
uh you know locke and i watch horror
movies together and now we've kind of
gotten you know
16 now now we're watching some
some of the movies from my list of my
favorite movies that
he i wouldn't let him watch up until now
and
when you get when you're looking at a
total running time of like two and a
half
three hours for some of these movies
that is a lifetime
for a teenager these days yeah my i've i
told
i told my kids i'm like you don't know
how to watch a movie you can't do it
well but you don't watch a show well but
what they'll do is
they will binge a television show yeah
they'll sit down
they'll sit down for five or six hours
and watch a whole season of a television
show
but the feeling of them having some sort
of control
of them being able to like take a break
between episodes
because it's naturally broken up that i
mean that's why in theory
and theory i know quibby did had
had a really bad launch but like
something like quibby
made a lot of sense on paper because it
was it was a it was designed for
mobile i watched a couple of shows on
there and like
the whole like flipping to vertical and
the way that that actually changed the
interac
it changed it in a way that was cooler
than i expected it to be
um but also the fact that you know
depending on the show it's like this is
broken up into bite-sized pieces but
it's telling a longer story
i mean i didn't get into any other
content but i only tried a couple of
things
but in theory it made sense it's like
let's go mobile
let's have a bias towards vertical let's
make it into bite-sized pieces that i
don't understand
it just they got a bunch of
great talent to be in the shows and to
make the shows
all that to say is what i've observed is
that the thing that you're battling is
the teenage
attention span yeah so board games i
can't even
fit right into you can't even get a kid
to watch a movie
with me yeah we just what was like
i'll say hey let's let's watch a movie
and they're like yeah i'm like okay well
let's watch a show
they're like all right well and it's
like you know locked
he'll they'll commit they'll commit to
like
40 minutes or 60 minutes with me and
that i take it personally it's like
that's all you can take of me
and then once that's oversight i'm gonna
go back in my room in order to watch
something watch something else without
me
but the thing that locke will do is he
and his friends will
maybe he he like he texted me the other
night is
with a friend and he was like dad what
was the name of that movie that we
watched for this and that happened
i was like send them the text i was like
it was this
and then i pick him up and uh he's like
i'm like hey did you you watched that
movie would you enjoy it he says yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and i asked him about a part he's
like we didn't finish it
didn't fit we didn't finish it like what
you didn't
finish the movie i don't understand how
the teenage brain works
and it wasn't because it was just like
yeah the night was over or whatever and
it's like we'll watch the rest of it
later
no it's like that again i in
in theory the quibby thing makes sense
it seems like it was the answer
to that but it just didn't it hasn't
worked yet i feel like it still will at
some point
i don't know i mean just went out
my uh like we
we've been re-watching and this is
lily's idea re-watching all the marvel
movies
she's a huge marvel fan and i was like
this is good i like a game plan the
kneels are watching all the marvel
movies we went through all the lord of
the rings and
you know we're we're watching survivor
and we're watching the lord of the rings
behind the scenes
like we have different things that are
ongoing and that is a
an appeal of series and then she kind of
applied that to marvel movies so then
it's like we're gonna watch all of these
she's so into him
but i'm like girl you gotta graduate's
not the right word
but it is what i kind of feel like i'm a
huge fan of all the marvel movies i love
watching them but there's something
you know you gotta you gotta watch like
good movies it's not what you gotta
graduate classic cinema
yeah cinematically to some more
artistic approaches to things you know
it's like yeah well
and i i feel like i broke that seal i
told you that black and i watched pulp
fiction
mm-hmm it was like
he kept leaning over because i remember
before i watched
it when we were in college um
and i we remember
we talked about this on the show when we
talked about it and the way it like
transformed what we thought was possible
with a movie so did he he was into it he
kept turning to me and he was just like
gosh like
making those faces and saying these
things like this is so great like
the very beginning when they're having
that conversation about the royale with
cheese like he just got this smile on
his face i was like yes he's
he he he understands he understands why
this is good
um and since then he's you know he
we've been watching a bunch of movies in
in from that time in my life
but um but still even when
if if you know friday night saturday
night rolls around and he's at home
uh you know he don't want to be with you
on a couch for three hours
yeah even though i've introduced him to
these great
movies still is this thing that's like
it's there's the threshold to overcome
to get them to be like ah yeah i wanna i
wanna sit down and
devote my evening to this yeah it's a
lot it's like i was like
let's watch a movie you know tonight
we're gonna watch a movie
we're going to watch a movie lando's not
here
lando was at your house for shepard's
birthday just the two of them
and they watched a movie and i was like
we can watch a movie that lando can't
watch
we're gonna watch the revenant
leonardo dicaprio that's one on the list
for me it's amazing
this one it's you know and um
they were a little reticent but i'm like
this is happening
it's a good movie you're going to like
it
you know it it's not too long into it
that there's the
there's the the bear attack and um
lily like stands up and i uh
honestly i had forgotten how traumatic
i mean how real yeah and relentless
yeah i mean i wouldn't call it a bear
attack i would call it three bear
attacks
i don't know if you remember we saw it
in the theater
and that was the only time i'd seen it
uh the bear attacked the dude
three different times and after the
first time you're like
oh my gosh i just don't feel like
i can keep watching this okay i don't
know if i can take this this is so
intense
and so literally i can't watch this and
you know what she was like like sit down
and watch this guy get maimed
yeah i was like well listen i was like
but i was like
you you loved us you like you watch all
these
you watch stuff that's just as intense
like there was i mean
that was real and scary but it yeah it
was a gory and
gory but so was us us was
very scary us is gory yeah
and she's like turns out it was it was
the intensity of it
but it was also i did and she's inching
her way to the door now and she's like i
just don't want to watch two guys chase
themselves
around chase around each other on the
wilderness
you know chase themselves around the
wilderness i can't even put the sentence
together but
you know what i'm saying chase woodward
wilderness i'm like well
i'm losing this battle but then christy
and and lincoln watched it with me
and i think um lincoln was like
that was a good movie he watched the
whole thing we watched the whole thing
it's a long movie very very it's a good
move cinematically i mean
yeah we want to we want to watch that
one together pretty mind-blowing but but
it's very intense
to get back a number of places get back
to games for a second
we're gonna play catan again this
weekend i'm getting back on that horse
now you talked about how you didn't
think you would be in the strategy games
now for the longest time
i've always just thought man i it makes
sense
that you would be into strategy games
and board games
because there's rules and there's a
system
and like yeah once you once you learn it
and execute it there are
specific results it see it seems to tie
into
your oneness on the yeah
i i i've not had a lot of experience and
i think i was thrown in the deep end
i have never played monopoly i've never
played it we we have that as
i told lily that and lily was like dad
who are you i mean how does this happen
i'm like
i was an only child like i didn't play i
didn't have a family i had a mom
like me and mom aren't going to sit down
and play monopoly you can't play with
just two people but my
this is this is what's always perplexing
to me and i is that
and i didn't watch movies most of the
time you know no but i didn't but here's
the thing
i played monopoly as a kid right but
i knew my family did not play board
games who did you play monopoly with
it would just be like in the time
between i was zero and 18
right and somewhere in childhood yeah
you'd be like you're at a
someone's home or you're at like your
cousin's house or
somebody has monopoly and you play it
my kids have played it i didn't seek
these things out they sought me out
i feel like you were purposely avoiding
them
it has to be that there was an
opportunity and you were like that's not
for me
has i think i was in anything strategy
or taking a long time
i think it was how my kids feel about
movies
i felt about these games it's like you
got to learn a lot
you got to like think hard and you can't
let up
like it just seems exhausting i'll play
connect four
i and listen the mclaughlin's the the
issue with the mclaughlins
is attention span and also
adhering to a system or rules
it's very difficult because you know
i i am by far
the most system-oriented person in my
family
mm-hmm and on the spectrum of people i'm
i'm
i'm i'm somewhere in the middle probably
in terms of like how much system there
is in my life right
but in my family i'm on the extreme
and so like rules and systems and having
to do things in a certain way
mixed with really competitive people who
don't like to lose
all of us all four of us is a it can
make for an incredible time
or it can make for like an ex somebody
is going to cry there's going to be some
explosiveness that happens
you know i've seen it on shepard's face
a number of times you know
when you're the youngest one and you're
the youngest one by five years
you know uh up until pretty recently it
was like he just doesn't have
the faculties to be super competitive in
some of these games right yeah
whatever we might be playing and so you
can see that like
when he makes a mistake that um oh
there it is he just lost the game he
just made a critical mistake
you get this look on his face like i've
blown it
you know i'm saying he's like he wants
to win so bad and it's just like
it's only and this is a flaw this is
something that i've had to
i continue to work on is like
are you having fun if you don't win
right
super competitive people have trouble
having fun if they don't
if they're not winning it's or if
they're doing something and they
and like i'm not good at this and i
don't think i'm going to be able to be
good enough at this to be competitive in
it
so i'm going to lose interest and so
those are the kind of
the factors but i think the fact that
everybody wants to win
ultimately is how you get people roped
into games in my family but
we started quarantine with games and
that they've completely fallen off
like we were playing scrabble
i mean we were scrabbling it up yeah
i've never played scrabble
again that's that's odd to me that you
haven't run across a scrabble
just a scrabble board somewhere on the
street that you just found yourself
playing
on like i didn't i mean like
grandparents wouldn't
never played games like i don't recall
i mean like as you and i we would never
play games
like i said we didn't have games yeah i
mean we didn't have scrabble
i played scrabble for probably the first
time as an adult because
jesse's parents had it and let's sit
down and play scrabble and i'm like
all right i know words apparently not
nearly as many as jessie's mom
i don't think that i am
yeah i it it's not really about am i
competitive or not
there's also a second factor along with
that that's like the group dynamic
yeah we're trying to set the scene for a
family
i'm saying yes i think i'm most
interested in that
with family my family and and none of us
are that competitive
like nobody gets that upset about
winning or losing or anything
and at least at this point maybe we'll
get more competitive
but it but but we'll be on that journey
together
i think that i was turned off by being
in environments where people were a lot
more competitive and then you just start
to feel
stupid it's kind of embarrassing like
it's a it's a bad feeling
when people are know how to play
something like
shepard's experience i think that was
part of my experience i'm like i don't
i don't want to have that i don't want
to look like a dummy
in front of everybody who's played
monopoly their whole life
so it's like i'm not you know so
and then that might come out as i'm not
competitive
so again i i can't even tell
like i actually don't well there is a
difference because with shepard what
he'll want to do
is he'll want to play let's start over
or let's play tomorrow night
so he doesn't he doesn't be like i don't
want to play this game again because i
lost he's like i want to play this game
again
because i lost but i don't think but
some i'm trying to set the stage for i
actually don't think i'm competitive you
think
i'm competitive i think i don't
i think there's something that you're
interpreting as i'm deep down
competitive but i think i'm interested
in something different
i'm not looking stupid i think when
this when the when the stage is set
right
and we're doing something that you
feel confident in like you're like like
i
understand this game and i have reason
to believe
that i am just as good or
better at the people that i'm playing
against
i think when this when the setting is
right when the circumstances are right
you want to win as much as i want to win
i think the difference is is that
if i enter a situation and i'm not good
at something i have to
really resist the urge to like okay with
poker for instance like
you know i started playing poker with my
my wife's family long time ago like
early in our marriage
and like it got competitive really
quickly and i'm like
if i'm going to have a chance of winning
at this
i gotta i i gotta understand it so i
went and got all these books about poker
and like read all these strategy about
poker because it was
instead of like you know what when you
guys play poker i'm not gonna be a part
of it
which is what you might do i'm just like
yeah which it was probably ultimately
more healthy because i'm just wasting
time learning how to play poker
into one sentence i'm not going to be
like a professional poker player but i
but then i'm like and i've even even
like within the past couple years i'll
find myself thinking like i need to get
a book on chess because i've never
really gotten good at chess
what no i don't i don't actually i mean
maybe if i want to and i think it would
be fun to learn
but not just so i could have like beat
somebody at chess
but i don't i've just observed like even
the games we play on gmm
uh like the the get the guessing the the
the countdown game
super competitive in that game because
i believe i have a chance yeah because
you're really good at that game
or like the pup puck game i'm like hey
this is a new one
you know i don't have to lose every time
but then at a certain point with like
i lose this dart game every time it's
like well
that's kind of frustrating because i
feel like i do try
on that one i'm not great at aim but
but yeah it's like i
and i think there's nothing wrong with
that there's nothing no i think we're
gonna be ashamed i think we're at
extremes because i think that
the thing that could be wrong with it is
not willing to
try something and get better at
something in order to
enjoy like the competition part of it
is i mean you if you can only point to
one example or two examples on the show
given all the things we compete against
it's just
it's just not the thing i'm most
interested in
so i don't think i'm not i'm certainly
not competitive to the same
level that you are because i'm not i'm
not interested in winning
i think what i'm getting at is once once
the circumstances are set and you're
committed to the game
i can see in your eyes that you want to
win that is very rare
beca i think it takes a lot for the
circumstances to to be
to be right i'm just saying in those
moments and so
so but yeah some but i am generally not
competitive but they're
like sports but there are people like
games but there are people who okay
catchphrase you're super competitive in
catchphrase
i think it's i think and there are
people who aren't i think you're
misinterpreting that
i think it's fun to be really into it
like the theatricality of it but
i don't really care if i win or lose
like
a lot of times when i play catchphrase
i'll like
i'll give clues in a very weird way
because i just think it's
fun and it and because if there's a
there's a timer i'm like
and it's going to go i don't bl but
there's also strategy in that i'm all
right
you could take doing weird clues early
on in the clock is
there's a strategy because then you give
it to the next person there's less time
and then they get frustrated and it's
funny to watch them
get upset but it's not about winning or
losing it's just about the social
dynamics are amusing
to me i've known people who i would say
are truly not competitive
like you can tell that they really
at no point do they get engaged to the
to the point where they would
actually really want to win it's like
who ca i don't and i just i'm saying
that okay i will definitely concede that
you're not as competitive as me but
you're more competitive than you give
yourself credit i think i'm adaptable to
sometimes when people are competitive
and that's how they're having a good
time like
it's not fun to be it's a killjoy to not
participate and the way you participate
yeah
because you're competitive i think
you're misinterpreting
me as being competitive when i'm just
being
playful like i'm actually like i'm here
to play
i'm here i don't i want to contribute to
the fun that's being had and the
climate is competition
but i personally am not driven i'm
driven by having a good time
and i don't and i know i have one
i can either be competitive and that
will be fun for everybody or i'll be the
person who's
who's not and then it's it it it's a
debbie downer it destroys it
so when you do something well
and don't think about i think you're
also isolating it to games but like
anything well any anything that you do
in your career
like i'm trying to do this well i'm
trying to
be a certain way about this i'm trying
to create this piece of i
i guess my definition of competition is
just
much wider as well because what i'm
saying is i mean
i feel like competitiveness is what
is one of the elements that has gotten
us to where we're at
in our career like and it is i don't
mean like oh i want to get more views
than this other channel i mean sometimes
it might come down to that but it's not
really that
it's more like i'm competing against
myself like
ultimately everybody wants to be
important in some way right and people
who are
entertainment kind of achieve that and
find their purpose a lot of times
in you know eliciting a reaction from
people
and i would say that you are actually
even more focused
and committed to getting a reaction from
a crowd or from a
from an individual than i am you think
about like the way that you're
super you know i'm much i'm much less
concerned about things like
where is this thing and where is the
camera and am i showing am i opening
this box in the right way
in my mind that's all competitive nature
it's like
that you have a commitment to excellence
and you may
you're you're thinking about
competitiveness in in like i'm throwing
a ball
faster than a person or not but like
you actually care about that stuff more
than i do and i and i would call that
sort of pers i would almost say it's a
relentless pursuit
of doing things in a certain way
perfection is not i mean
is it is attained by compare
comparison to like a standard
yes but i think it's a stretch to say
that that's competition like i'm
competing against the standard
now i also think this is
i think it's a little muddied by
i don't know i do you do you get from me
in this conversation that like i
judge you for being compass
[Music]
okay so we're breaking in kiko
i don't envy what the decisions you've
had to make in editing this but
um apparently kiko has decided that what
you just heard
was like the truncated point and the end
of this
episode and and the reason being
and then next week you'll get the the
continuation for
over an hour of the rest of our
conversation which like
veered deep into introspection and
arguments and
an apology i i'm sensationalizing
because i i really do want
you to you gotta i wanna i want him to
listen to this to part two
but and you know
because i i think it's um i'm gonna be
thinking a lot about it
just to set the stage because you're
gonna have to wait a week to listen to
it
so as you know we were talking about
board games
uh and i and i've talked about this many
times
i've talked about my theory that link is
just as competitive as me in quotes
um and that led to a conversation
and i've never liked it when you said
that and i i don't know exactly why
about uh a
boy it got very it just got very deep it
got very personal and very vulnerable
from both sides um and we ended up
talking about the dynamics of
our friendship and our creative
partnership and how we think differently
about it and what we how we think the
same about it
and i just didn't want that conversation
to get buried at the end of the com
of an entire episode about something
else
about board games and movies
and our kids and so yeah
so you may be frustrated with us that
we're making you wait
another week for it but we we we poured
a lot of ourselves into it and i don't
want it to get buried and not to be
competitive but
if you're frustrated you can direct your
frustration at link
uh because that was this was his idea
but
i don't i don't like having a two and a
half hour podcast
when it's like i believe this is the
right choice
actually and it and and it
it it it puts something front and center
that we wanted
the most people listen to and and not
lose heart before they get to it and it
allows us to not have to sit down and
record another episode
which is always good you know so it's a
it's
it's a win-win so
stay tuned to next week for that but for
now use
your biscuits let us know about board
games
i mean we we've just finished having the
part of the conversation you're going to
next week so it's like
this is i think we said some good things
about board games
um yeah and uh is it katan or katan you
could tell us about that
uh you know i'm sure you would like to
recommend board games to us
or any type of family family-oriented
games that that we could continue to buy
or not family just once where you put
the kids to bed and things get dirty
those are good games too
hashtag ear biscuits and we will
speak at you next week which will be the
continuation
but we're about to record an intro for
that that makes sense of it
yeah so there's lots of different pieces
let's do that now
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best